with reaction now author of what is
going to be a very important big book
defeating big government socialism
saving america's future by the way
amazon.com we'll put it up on
hannity.com as well fox news contributor
form speaker of the house newt gingrich
you know that really is what we're
battling against here because new green
dealism when you look at the actual
policy is redistribution it is socialism
is it not
sure all you have is a
combination of big government socialism
and
a kind of woke
really sort of secular religion
and the problem that that biden has is
that he can't break loose from it i mean
you know i know most people in the
country know there are ways to solve
these problems that make life better for
america and to make america a stronger
country
all of those solutions
just drive the the big government
socialist and the left's crazy and so
biden sits there and does more of what
doesn't work and then tries to blame
putin or somebody the big corporations i
mean there's always somebody else i've
you know i i was struck the other day
that
the biden presidency might be called
uh from
uh the basement to the bicycle because
if you watch him uh he spends every
weekend bicycling he's not engaged he's
not helping the people of ukraine he's
certainly not solving our problems he
doesn't seem to be even aware of how bad
the border is to our south
the crime problem which cropped up again
in new york today in a very vivid
powerful way it doesn't seem to affect
him uh you have to wonder i mean what
kind of
total cocoon
are they living under that they don't
realize this is
we're drifting towards a disaster and
the american people are going to fire
him
look even even on covet they ran out of
tests over christmas uh how that
happened i don't know that's almost imp
an impossibility as we entered year
three the border a disaster the economy
i read the numbers a disaster energy
policies it was 2.42 cents a gallon
under donald trump i paid 479 a gallon
this weekend uh inflation 8.5 donald
trump left it at 1.4 whole uh whole
price is highest ever wholesale prices
11.2 donald trump left it at 1.6
these are not small changes every major
economist is now suggesting we are going
to hit a recession and it's going to be
bad now
the only way that i see that they can
get out of this is go back to trump's
policies and we know that's not going to
happen
well then that and that's the whole
problem
everything which works which is what
ronald reagan did what we did with the
contract with america what president
trump did all those things are obvious
and we know they work
but if you are in the secular religion
of the left and you you know get
together with your friends and you think
that figuring out which pronoun to use
is more important than solving crime or
you figure out that brainwashing third
graders about transgender behavior is
more important than controlling the
border i mean just go down the list
i think by any
reasonable historic standards
these people are crazy i don't think
they can change because i think they're
crazy and i think that if biden tried to
change uh they would erupt overnight uh
and you would have an extraordinary
civil war in the democratic party
what do you make of quinnipiac it's it's
not a right wing or conservative poll by
any measure they have joe's approval
rating at 33 percent they have his
approval with independence at 26
recent polls have showed a dramatic
demographic shift of african americans
and hispanic americans towards the
republican party then you've got the bad
economy that's impacting everybody the
disastrous afghanistan withdrawal and
frankly a lack of urgency from my
perspective as it relates to ukraine and
providing them the munitions to beat
back vladimir putin's forces without one
american boot on the ground
well let me let me start by pointing out
that when hillary clinton offered advice
as she did recently her husband lost 53
seats and for the first time
in 40 years the republicans controlled
the house that was their first term when
barack obama last week offered his
advice
he lost 63 seats
and lost control of the house so having
them offer advice on the election i
thought was terrific and i hope that
they take their advice because it will
be a total disaster but the quinnipiac
poll is pretty obvious
um you know i i filled up uh
my my truck the other day it was about
85 dollars callista filled up her car i
have a hybrid so mine's slightly cheaper
uh and she paid i think 91 dollars to
fill up her car you go to the grocery
store uh and the prices have all gone up
um
one of the folks i work with said
they're not even going to try to buy
steak in the near future because it's
absurdly too expensive we're having a
disaster with chickens in the midwest
where we have an avian flu that's
leading to the killing of literally
millions of chickens
wheat is going to go up dramatically
because ukraine and russia were huge
wheat exporters so when you look around
if you're a normal everyday person
and you don't understand you're supposed
to believe whatever brainwashing the new
york times of the washington post put
out this morning
you go in in your life
and you're seeing real problems
put in making ends meet and you start
hearing about a recession
a recession in this economy coming right
after covid will be extraordinarily
painful
and there's one person they're going to
blame for it that's joe biden they're
not going to go out there and sit and
scratch their head and think gee i
wonder how this happened and they're not
going to believe that putin did it
i think they'll blame the whole
democratic party which brings us to your
book defeating
big government socialism
out in just a couple of weeks uh
i mean that really captures the moment
that we're in because that's the
ideological battle that we're now going
through as a country isn't it
sure and i think president trump's
election uh set
firebells off among everybody on the
hard left because he was a real change
agent he was moving us back towards the
america that works you were pointing out
the numbers a while ago they're
astounding the things he achieved in
four years despite the elite media
despite the fbi despite the whole
bureaucracy fighting him
he nonetheless achieved amazing things
and the country was in pretty good shape
just before covet hit and i think if
trump were still in charge the country
be back in very good shape right now so
we know how to solve these problems and
i think
what i try to point out in defeating big
government socialism this is a moment
not just to talk about the incompetence
of a handful of leaders this is a moment
to recognize that the very core values
they believe in do not work
that this is a values and philosophy
problem and that those folks have got to
be defeated
decisively and get america back on the
right track
creating jobs
stable money controlling the border
controlling criminals you know doing
something bold like favoring the
innocent victim over the criminal i mean
that seems like it's common sense unless
of course you're on the woke left
and you have some really weird idea
about how the world works
yeah i'm well said uh they could
probably use a lesson and maybe take a
page out of 1994. i was there that night
uh when you did become speaker i was the
mc and uh it may be time for putting the
signature to paper and promise what you
will do if given the opportunity to
serve the american people uh mr speaker
we look forward to having the first
interview with the book and you being
back here thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else